welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro filling in for Eric Voss
while he is out on paternity leave yay
Eric and this is a breakdown of the
ninth episode of season 7 of Rick and
Morty titled Mort Ragnar a play on the
third Thor film Thor Ragnarok the
episode isn't a direct parody of that
film but does contain a lot of MCU
references which we be pointing out in
this breakdown this is the penultimate
episode of season 7 a season that has
seen some big changes to the Smith
family both in the show and behind the
scenes now let's dive into it but before
we do be sure to check out nerd rot.
shop where you will always find the
latest and greatest in new rock stars
merch there's always something new being
added to the site including some fun new
holiday themed merch that's perfect for
the nerdy fan on your gift list shopping
at nerd r. shop is a great way to
support the channel so check it out
today thanks this episode opens with
Jerry in what looks like a very
stereotypical version of Heaven his
grandmother meets him but says pop pop
isn't coming because it's getting
annoying he's yanked back to life and
wakes up in the garage Rick has
apparently been killing him multiple
times to see if there's a heaven this
whole thing is very reminiscent of
flatliners the 1990 movie where Med
students bring themselves back from the
brink of death kefir Sutherland was in
that this is an interesting experiment
for Rick who has confessed to being an
atheist multiple times on the show so
apparently there's an infinite energy
source out there that uses people's
cultural view of Heaven to reel them in
Morty there's kind of a heaven kind of I
mean there definitely is for a
neurotypical like your father Rick isn't
interested in getting in heaven but
harnessing the energy of the dimension
but Rick search for energy could just be
a cover for a more personal search for
meaning Rick has been feeling rudderless
since killing Rick Prime earlier this
season it's possible that our Rick is
still holding on to hope that his
murdered wife Diane is out there
somewhere but he's framing it as a
search for energy because of his pride
at least that's what I thought when this
whole episode started he doesn't want to
go to Jerry's christiany 80s movie
version of heaven but finds one that
he's more interested in he tells Morty
Morty pack your Parker we're going to
Norway Rick and Morty set up a base in
Norway Rick says that he's going going
to Valhalla in Norse mythology Valhalla
is the Hall of slain Warriors a version
of the afterlife where Warriors killed
in battle Feast on boore meat and drink
liquor that flows from the udder of a
goat the Legends say they will stay
there until Odin needs them to help
fight the Giants this isn't the first
time Rick and Morty have been in a Norse
mythology setting there's a spawn conon
which stands for sponsored content video
from last year where they go to the
world of the video game God of War
Ragnarok Rick has a clone of himself in
a jar the computer says Phoenix protocol
in initiated this is Rick's contingency
plan for his death where his
Consciousness is uploaded into a waiting
clone we've seen it use in episodes like
Big Trouble in Little Sanchez and Edge
of tomori Rick Die Repeat Rick says he
needs to die in glorious battle to get
into Valhalla he produces a Pokeball
that contains Bigfoot a death by
Sasquatch was foreshadowed in this
season when the president assembles a
half-ass task force to deal with the
unity hive mind one of the members is
flee florp an alien who can maybe
predict the future with childlike
drawings he drew Rick getting mauled by
Bigfoot which actually happens in the
this episode I got to give us a little
pat on the back for this one we
predicted it here at new rockstars and
even made it our thumbnail in our
breakdown for that episode still taking
us to school Eric Voss nicely done Rick
enters a chamber covered in Norse runes
this looks like troll this one looks
like courage this one looks like need or
hardship this could be elder tree or
feminine energy dance or sexuality
honestly all four of those basically the
same thing this one could mean
protection although the line across the
top might be altering that meaning
somehow Rick takes a slug of his flask
could be to numb the pain for his
impending death or just because you know
he's ricked he tosses down the Pokeball
and releases Bigfoot who almost
immediately smashes his face to a pulp
this is chillingly similar to the bare
fisted beating Rick gave Rick Prime in
episode 5 I guess Rick is Bigfoot's
Nemesis his Rick Prime if you will Rick
materializes in the middle of a field
and exclaims I'm dead Rick a call back
to the adjective based Ricks like I'm
tiny Rick and then now you bous I'm
pickle Rick he's killed again in the
middle of a Viking battle and
materializes in valhal he's greeted by a
viking with a down arrow tattoo that
looks kind of like the markings on the
DC character Red Tornado although this
guy's Arrow seems to be pointing to his
dong we can see a tapestry on the wall
featuring two birds this is probably a
reference to Odin's Ravens hugin and
munin but we're also reminded of the two
crows storyline from season 5 great
Odin's Ravens Rick heads to the
blacksmith for some armor and sees a
hammer clearly inspired by Thor's Moler
and knocks out the blacksmith back at
the research station Bigfoot tricks
Morty into opening his cell by
pretending to pray and cry over Rick's
dead body Morty fell for a similar prey
when caught tactic from previous Leon in
the season 6 episode full meta Jack Rick
Bigfoot crushes Morty casually ambles
out and then tries to get at Rick's
clone Morty lands in the battlefield
gets killed and ends up in Valhalla this
afterlife seems to have a two-step
process where you die in the battlefield
and then move to the hall the Vikings
take him to Rick who is using their
tools to build his energy machine he
casually tells them I'm actually Odin
Odin yep Thor's father Spider-Man's
Uncle Etc Rick has apparently mashed up
the MC U Marvel Cinematic Universe and
actual Norse mythology but there is a
what if comic from 1982 where Aunt May
marries Odin instead of Uncle Ben so
that's definitely a deep cut to that
nicely done Rick and Morty riters Morty
rides up on a Dopey looking goat and
Rick blasts the Vikings when they call
him a witch this isn't the first time
Rick has been a reluctant deity in a
mort well- lived he becomes a messiah to
a world of video game NPCs that have
Morty's fragmented Consciousness back at
the lab Bigfoot is trying to smash the
Rick clone out of his chamber he uses
Rick's body to whack it eventually he
cracks the glass using one of Rick's
legs that has a cybernetic implant this
causes the Clone to go into survival
mode and it runs around like an idiot
since it doesn't have Rick's
Consciousness uploaded into it yet I
guess this is all it's capable of
Bigfoot chases the Clone into town and
is captured by Norwegian police who look
to be wearing real life accurate
uniforms nice detail two agents pull up
and take Bigfoot they have little golden
Illuminati pins on their jackets they
bring Bigfoot before the pope who says
hello Bigfoot I'm going a pop this
reminds me of the punchline to this
classic sketch from the state hey I'm
the Pope the Pope says he's going to use
Bigfoot to kill the church's enemies
because they can't kill anyone
themselves they even have the Rick clone
crucified as bait to control Bigfoot
they even cover up his nauy bits with a
leaf something the Catholic Church would
often do to ancient works of art they
deemed improper you know what there's
nothing worse than a blank wall I mean
look at me I'm sitting here against an
infinite fields of
blue these walls could use some
personality somebody called displate
displate is one of a metal poster
designed to capture the things that you
are most passionate about and make them
easy to show off display posters are
magnet mounted so they're easy to
rearrange and because they're metal they
won't Bend or crinkle or curl at the
edges displayed has a ton of posters
from popular fandoms like Marvel Star
Wars DC Lord of the Rings and more we've
got a few Star Wars posters for the
office and they look awesome display
ships worldwide in four to 5 days which
means you could be out of your blue
dungeon in less than a week ah not me I
live here now to get started with
displayed and support new rockstars just
click the link in the description below
use the code rockstars and you'll get
22% off your order if you order one or
two displates and 33% off your order if
you order three once again just click
the link in the description below and
use the code Rockstar to get 22% off in
order for one or two displates and 33%
off for in order three back in Viking
heaven Rick continues to work on his
machine while Morty defends him from
Viking hordes using a chain gun Rick
says they're not going home until he
finishes His Infinite Energy machine you
think the next time these see a naked
man on the battlefield they're going to
give him a beer in a montage Morty kills
the Vikings with increasingly brutal
weapons landmines a mortar wooden drones
that he flies using a wooden VR headset
each time they die they teleport back to
the hall Rick says he can use the
infinite energy to send them back in new
bodies Morty wonders if the Vikings
won't just attack the lab Rick has a
plan for that though we see a missile
hit the hall and the Vikings
rematerialize back in the crater that it
leaves Rick and Morty fly overhead in
makeshift wings that look like the
jankier versions of the vultures in
Spider-Man homecoming Rick is carrying
the hammer and has a little crown that
says God on it he calls Morty Spider-Man
running with his MCU Norse mythology
mashup he has Morty lasers some
Commandments about not going near the
energy relay into the Rocks back in the
Bigfoot be Story the pope uses Rick's
dumb clone is bait he drops it in a cult
of satanists they look kind of like the
cult members from Resident Evil 4 but
with blood pentagrams on their heads in
one shot one of is actually sucking
blood off her fingers Bigfoot wrecks
shop at the Satanist layer we see him
knocked down an arch cover in what looks
like alchemical symbols and or demonic
sigils an alter to the right of the
screen has a book which might be the key
of Solomon a magic textbook from the
14th or 15th century the pope recaptures
Bigfoot and drops him into the offices
of gaj jungas a secular nudie magazine
probably an odd to Hustler who often
made fun of and antagonized the church
Bigfoot does target practice on a devil
Target using a crossbow Gauntlet it kind
of reminds me of the Phantom Blade
weapon from the Assassin's Creed games
Bigfoot then gets dropped into a
non-domination Candle factory the pope
gives him a communicator that he says he
he got from a predator he's of course
talking about the monster from the
franchise of the same name that wears a
similar multi-purpose Gauntlet the Pope
says he traded three muskets for it we
saw the predator in episode one of this
season how poopy got his poop back yeah
that's the real name of that episode in
that episode The Predator gives Mr PB a
musket after he accepts the fact that
his wife has moved on we've seen the
Predators exchange muskets various times
in that Series so it is their currency
Rick and Morty zap themselves back into
their new clones but their energy relay
isn't working Bigfoot breaks in and
smacks them around Bigfoot uses the
Predator Gauntlet to tell Rick that the
reason he's so mad is that Rick thought
he was stupid that's a big theme in this
episode Rick thinks he's smarter than
everyone else and by most metrics he is
but he's proven to be pretty stupid when
it comes to emotions and relationships
Rick shows he's working on his emotional
intelligence by tapping into Bigfoot's
pain he says he'll help Bigfoot get out
from under the thumb of the Pope he even
upgrades the Predator Gauntlet so
Bigfoot's voice is handsfree and doesn't
have the halting speaking spell quality
to it Bigfoot demonstrates his new voice
by saying in a world where time actually
is money here he's probably referring to
In Time the Justin Timberlake sci-fi
movie with the time equals money premise
it is packed with tons of strained time
puns they sneak into the Vatican Bigfoot
sneaks past the guard by tapping on his
Gauntlet and using his halting speech
again so he doesn't tip anyone off that
Rick upgraded it the guard takes a
selfie with Rick and Morty supposedly
dead bodies and says he needs to poke
them with a spear this could be a
reference to the crucifixtion of Jesus
where the Bible details that Jesus was
stabbed with a spear by the Romans to
make sure he had died and in of blood
water flowed from the wound either way
this blows their cover and they go in
guns blazing the pope has tapped into
the infinite energy and roasts them
sending them back to Valhalla the tubes
of the machine and the floating midair
being very Emperor esque as seen in Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker they beam
back into clones and Bigfoot goes into a
summer Bigfoot summer even has a bit of
an underbite Rick reveals a closet of
various models of Portal guns he takes
the classic Model but we see a wooden
one kind of like the tech they were
making in Valhalla there's one held
together with duct tape with a SP spoon
for a handle each time he dies he'll
take another one off the wall what
follows reminds me of the repeating
deaths from this season of Loki or the
doramu I've come to bargain scene from
the first Doctor Strange movie and of
course Edge of Tomorrow which the show
parody in the season 4 episode edge of
tomori Rick Die Repeat Rick and Morty
die again and again by the Pope's
Valhalla fire they give Bigfoot a new
non-summer dadbod body he says me
instead of I me love it me dial it back
you don't want to come across like a
muppet he's probably referencing Cookie
Monster we love
cookie and I'll head off any comments
telling me that Sesame Treet characters
aren't Muppets they do in fact count as
Muppets we checked in one of these
attempts we see Rick has his armor from
the pro morus episode in season 4 Morty
has what looks like an upgraded version
of his armor from look who's purging now
in season 2 they get chopped up grid
style kind of like the stars team does
by the Red Queen in the first Resident
Evil movie man that's a deep cut Bigfoot
tells Rick that the pope has other
monsters that can help them on their
next attempt the Pope says I can do this
all day Cap's famous catchphrase Rick
summons versions of the classic
Universal monsters there's Dracula the
mummy Frankenstein's monster wolf man
and the Creature from the Black Lagoon
the pope zaps them all back to vahalla
and we see everyone in their human forms
the mummy says this afterlife smells
like beer obviously being from ancient
Egypt his afterlife would have been
totally different and presumably less
hard drinking than the Viking one Rick
admits to the Vikings that he's been
playing them they chase them back to the
energy relay and use the universal
monsters as decoys to get away the pope
asked asks if they brought the Harlem
Globe Trotters this time the basketball
stunt men did a ton of cameos back in
the day on shows like Scooby-Doo and
Gilligan's Island since the Vikings took
back the relay the pope loses his powers
Rick traps the Pope in a Pokeball and it
wriggles around before settling much
like it does when you catch a wild
Pokemon in the games Rick grudgingly
makes the popy ball pun we were all
thinking of they take Bigfoot back to
the woods and do a tearful why can't you
go back to where you came from scene
much like the goodbye scene from Harry
and the Henderson they even use the same
sappy orchestral score post-edit scene
takes place in a fighting arena that
looks a lot like the one we see in maau
and shangi and the legend of the 10
Rings it's another MCU reference Rick is
facing off against a Pokemon trainer
that looks like a legally dissimilar Ash
Ketchum the trainer throws out a
dinosaur looking Pokemon that looks
legally dissimilar from Charizard and
Rick throws out the pope who is
terrified everybody flees when police
sirens are heard we cut to the cops
comforting the Pokémon fighters and they
reveal that the brainless Rick clone is
now the pope that's it for us today I'll
be back to break down the season 7
finale next week go ahead and follow me
on the internet at Hector is funny and
at Heroes reforged on YouTube follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything that you
love thank you so much for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]
bye